After big drops in Asia and Europe, it was Wall Street's turn.
In its first trading day since the S&P downgrade,...
...the Dow Jones Industrial Average plunged below 11,000,...
...losing 635 points in the worst sell-off in nearly three years.
Some say what may be happening is a new realization that the global economy led by the US is slowing down.
But many in New York believe Washington's failure to come to grips with the nation's growing debt...
...is the reason why markets are so spooked.
The White House, for the most part, agrees.
In his first comment since the historic downgrade,...
...President Barack Obama said the US did not need a credit rating agency...
...to say that Washington politics is broken.
Markets will rise and fall...
...but this is the United States of America.
No matter what some agency may say,...
...we've always been and always will be a AAA country.
But others say the problem is that what happens in the US...
...is bound to have an economic impact in other countries.
The good news, the president says...
...is that the market turmoil may be the catalyst Congress needs to tackle the nation's long - term problems.
The bad news say market analysts, is that the Dow has now lost about 15% of its value in the last two weeks.
Mil Arcega, VOA News.